yeah with the new die hard movie coming
out in about a month I figure it's time
to review the die hard movies so we're
going to start out with the Genesis the
movie about a man who stood between a
terrorist and his dead na dos
diehard is funny doing a video like this
because I have to assume there are
people out there who don't know the
premise of die hard for all two of you
here it is die hearts the story of John
McClane played by Bruce Willis arguably
the most relatable protagonist ever in
movies ever he's at the Nakatomi Plaza
in LA he's at a party for his wife's
work and then a bunch of baddies led by
Alan Rickman aka Severus Snape take
control of the building they're like we
have this under control
all the hostages are downstairs what
could go wrong except the fact that no
one really counted on Bruce Willis being
in the building also so now Bruce Willis
is this lone soldier this one person
they don't even know is up there at
first he starts causing havoc for the
people and here we are John McClane is
the inner ears that for German
terrorists of cinema that thing were
they're like yeah that's obnoxious and
there's not much we can do about it and
it sucks we can try but we're just
whittling down our crew if it sounds
familiar it's because it is a lot of
movies have tried to do that premise
sense but no movie has nailed it like
die hard
like every year or two filmmakers and
studios alike all right we got to make
the new die hard the die hard of modern
day problem is die hard still holds up
as a sweet ass action movie so die hard
is the die hard of modern day don't try
to mess with [ __ ] cool thing is die hard
takes place in the Golden Age of action
cinema you know if you're the lone
gunman trying to fight off terrorists
and you're stuck in a building there are
no cell phones there's no help the only
help John McClane has is Carl Winslow
from Family Matters he's talking with
him on the radio and I love this this
cop on cop on screen chemistry is not
going to be matched until end of watch
I'm serious about that it's really cool
that the only real support John McClane
has in this whole thing is a cop that he
doesn't even see he's talking with him
on the walkie-talkie hard to pull off
yes it is does die hard pull it off with
aces you bet you see in a movie like
this it's important to have a really
relatable hero and Bruce Willis
completely completely embodies that I
will never actually relate to Arnold
Schwarzenegger in any action movie he's
ever been in Sam goes with Stallone a
lot of these old-school action heroes so
they get Bruce Willis who's all the
badassery yet all of the humanizing
elements anyone who watches die hard
relates to John McClane immediately when
I was watching die hard just today just
you know
prep for this I was like as far as
situations like this where you got the
lone gunman trying to take out a fleet
of bad guys this is the only movie where
I absolutely put myself in his position
when he's talking on the radio I
visioned myself talking on the radio and
just everything I would think I would do
he does which is my way of saying
anything I would want to actually think
I would actually do I'm not as badass as
him but the movie makes you feel like
you could be and as much as I should and
absolutely will profess that Bruce
Willis completely carries this movie
that's not discrediting the supporting
cast the supporting cast nails it every
person you want in a situation like die
hard you got you want your douchebag cop
trying to get in the way of everything
you got him you want your [ __ ] big
mouth nosy news reporter we got him -
played by Walter Peck from Ghostbusters
so you know this guy's gonna get under
your skin you want your bearded snobby
dick bag completely blowing your cover
thinking he's actually helping the
situation yo John Boy Ellis he's in it
and as great as John McClane is Alan
Rickman as the bad guy Hans Gruber kills
it you would swear to God that Alan
Rickman should be the most boring son of
a [ __ ] you've ever seen on screen but
he's always great to see in a bad guy
role because he talks like this like he
shouldn't be impressed with anything
which should be boring but you take is
endearing
intellect now bring me my dead Annette
oh there's a scene where John McClane is
face to face with him and they're
talking and I love this scene so much
again one of those scenes were after
this everyone was like oh hey yeah you
know that script you're writing make a
scene like that in that movie and not do
it as well is the subtext I hearts one
of those movies were a couple times I'm
like you didn't think that through and
writing the script agenda proves to
myself that I can suspend my disbelief
to sit back and enjoy a movie that's
completely badass I don't need to
nitpick it all the time you know like
the scene where Carl Winslow is talking
to his boss aka the douchebag from
Breakfast Club is a scene earlier where
John McClane had to get the cops
attention what to do we'll take the body
you just shut up and just throw them out
the window that will get someone's
attention this dick bags like I was
probably some disgruntled office worker
left to his death I was just thinking
like the body has gunshot holes in him
what did you think happened you think he
was just like stupid dick bag boss makes
me work on Christmas Eve and doesn't
appreciate me but I'll show him
I brought a gun today but I'm not going
to shoot him I'm gonna I'm gonna shoot
myself in the legs cocking balls then
jump off this building suppose it could
have happened but that just that
wouldn't be my first thought obviously
there's a bearded bad guy in there
played by Alan Rickman is all I bring me
my dead Aneta the only thing it could be
die hard has great action great
characters a great lead character a
great villain it has everything you want
in an action movie like this it defined
a genre it defined a hero and it defined
a catchphrase
you became [ __ ] this is so
nonchalant in this movie - you know
after this it's a big deal you have to
say it in every die-hard movie Alan
Rickman calls him cowboy he's all like
how boy his response was Jesse be gay
[ __ ] and you just stop and go
yeah that's the perfect response for
that situation in short my friends die
hard absolutely is awesome tacular
it's funny some Christmas movie reviews
that I've done I'm like oh hey what's
your favorite Christmas movie and some
people like this diehard count I just
think to myself like yes and we'll play
race your favorite protagonist in any
movie ever that's here of generally
speaking whoever he or she may be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more you big a a [ __ ]